[Music]
where were ant-man and the wasps
did you see the bassoon where was tip
chair good question no I mean really I
have no idea I mean I don't remember
being asked to be in their movie just
saying maybe they were on their way but
they went subatomic maybe they were
they're pretty tiny and there were
definitely some ants of a condor so
maybe there are in this theme place is
Hawkeye Kimura saw spider-man I was
really looking forward to meeting the
wasp yeah no not that we're hey
everybody its charlie what a coincidence
that Marvel drops that teaser for the
ant-man and the wasp trailer that's
coming tomorrow right as I'm making my
top 10 WTF video for infinity war so
obviously careful for spoilers if you
have not seen infinity war yet we'll be
talking about very specific plot details
and if you are brand new to the channel
be sure to subscribe to get all the
videos obviously there will be an
ant-man and the wasp trailer tomorrow
but starting with number 10 let's just
start with that teaser at the beginning
of the trailer where were ant-man and
the wasp
where was Hawkeye maybe they were in the
same place that Hawkeye was I love the
way that they built that into the actual
teaser for ant-man and the wasps they're
gonna use that for marketing for the
movie so we actually know where that
movie picks up now they released a
couple more details to give us an idea
for a kind of what's going on but
literally they give them a very brief
shout out there's an ant-man and a
spider-man now banners just reacting to
all the new heroes that have been around
since he's been gone remember he left
the earth at the end of Avengers age of
Ultron so everything that happened since
then he had to catch up on both of those
characters were bigger question marks
for different reasons
so Hawkeye was the big question mark
because he was a phase one classic
Avenger and it's like you know how you
gonna leave out one of the classic
Avengers out of this first part of
infinity war but the reason why a man of
the wasp was such a big question mark is
because their movie is coming out after
infinity war but we don't know where it
picks up in the timeline because at no
point during that trailer do they
reference what's going on during
infinity war we've learned since then
that a man and the wasp picks up before
infinity war starts in the timeline so
when we see him in the trailer getting
his little house arrest bracelet and
he's talking about
okay you know Civil War happened I got
arrested and the waswas sort of making
fun of him yeah you wouldn't gotten
caught if I was there with you helping
out this is all before Thanos's ship
touches down in New York City so a lot
of us have been theorizing that if they
go into the quantum realm during their
movie in time moves differently that
when they come out at the end of the
movie it will be post finger snap the
quantum realm will somehow protect them
from the effects of the reality changing
finger snap so I'll talk more about that
during my ant-man in the wasp trailer
video tomorrow morning but the way they
explained Hawkeye not being around is
that he was also on house arrest because
their families couldn't take it like he
didn't want to be away from his family
so he cut a deal and he's on house
arrest he'll be back in Avengers four
I'll talk more about him becoming the
Ronin version of the character in if his
family may have died because of the
finger snap when I do a new Avengers for
video number nine the timeline error
between spider-man homecoming in
infinity war so we finally validated
what's going on with that eight years
later at the beginning of homecoming the
Battle of New York / Tony Stark during
infinity war was six years ago the
Russos and Kevin Feige both confirmed
that the homecoming eight years later is
an error in date now no idea why they
let that roll on a two hundred million
plus dollar movie like why would they
send that out maybe someone just didn't
catch it in time or they weren't
thinking about it because changing a
date like that is relatively easy any 13
year old kid that has a basic
understanding of Adobe After Effects
could change that pretty quickly but let
it be known that it's six years later
not eight years later so maybe sometime
they'll change that but if you have the
blu-ray it still says eight years later
so number eight the Hulk cannot Hulk out
why can he not Hulk out there are a lot
of people to think that it's because
he's afraid of Thanos but remember when
he is back on earth he comes back from
the sanctum and they're looking at the
ship at Ebenezer off on the street there
Tony Stark says to banner
do you want a piece of this and he's
like no but when do I get whatever I
want so he tries to change into the Hulk
and it won't work
it's like performance issues what's
going on you're embarrassing me in front
of the wizard the only time that the
Hulk ever actually speaks to him is when
he's in the park briefly and then at the
end of the movie
when he's still inside the Hulkbuster
and you can hear the voice of the Hulk
scream no as he's trying to change so
here's the thing about that I would
believe that he's afraid of vanos
because he was beaten if he were
fighting fan oohs in this moment but
Thanos is nowhere to be found
this is Squidward in Kolob city in here
the Hulk did not fight them he has no
reason to be afraid of these two people
like at the end of the movie when he's
fighting Coe obsidian and he's kind of
talking to the hook like what's going on
you big green and Hulk screams
no and doesn't want to come back out he
says fine I'll do it myself if they do
give him those lines of dialogue to him
when Thanos was running that Avengers
gauntlet then it would have made more
sense but there's no reason for hope to
be afraid when banner sees that Thor
comes with Stormbreaker lands the field
and starts just wiping out all the
enemies like he has that line of
dialogue where he says you all are so
screwed now because Thor has brought his
greatest weapon to bear so we'll find
out more about that during Avengers 4
because banner says we have a lot to
figure out pal so implying that the
problem with the Hulk is a little more
complicated than him just being afraid
number seven of the big question that I
got on a couple of the videos that I've
been posting this past weekend how did
they know snow who Tony Stark was tony
was surprised You Know Who I am oh yes
you're not the only one that's cursed
with knowledge the easiest way to
explain that is is that it was after the
Battle of New York Thanos found out that
his attack had failed and someone just
conveyed that information the Avengers
stopped the attack so that's probably
when he found out who Tony Stark was but
number 6 what's up with that second
Infinity Gauntlet at the Dwarven space
Forge or is that just a mold
either way they can make another
gauntlet if they need to
which makes you think about the melted
one that Thanos has so right now the
gauntlet has been melted the gem still
look like they work just fine the way
that Eitri explains the actual gauntlet
itself is that Thanos asked him to make
a device that would allow him to wield
the power of all the stones together so
just like Stormbreaker just like Mjolnir
have special enchantments on them they
have magical properties that allow them
to either wield the power of the Bifrost
or like Thor can send his hammer all
for the universe and it will come to him
whenever he calls it which also his
Stormbreaker too if you guys didn't
notice that he throws Stormbreaker and
it comes right back to him so it also
works a little bit like Mjolnir but the
actual gauntlet itself isn't just a
simple gauntlet that someone would wear
into a battle it also has special
magical enchantments that allow it to
wield the power of all the Infinity
stones together so the idea then is is
that the Avengers won't be able to use
Santos's version of the gauntlet because
it's melted but they can reuse the
Infinity stones by forming a new
gauntlet so we'll talk more about that
when I do an Avengers 4 video because
it's kind of speculation but I think
what we're meant to take away from the
melty gauntlet is that the Avengers
won't be able to steal that from him and
just use it outright they'll have to
somehow either fix the gauntlet or make
a new one at this dwarven space Forge
number 5
Loki really did die after the first Thor
movie
fana says no resurrections this time
that's what he was referring to
Loki died when he fell through that
black hole Thanos resurrected him which
is why Loki looked so hard up when he
comes to earth in the first Avengers
film like he hasn't slept in forever
it's because he was dead and resurrected
so I think a big part of believing when
characters are dead or the method of
their death like everybody believes that
these ashed people will come back even
though half of all life in the universe
was a race well yeah they'll come back
somehow The Avengers are gonna fix this
and Avengers four number four this is a
big one everybody hates star-lord now
why couldn't star-lord wait five more
seconds before wailing on Thanos his
face literally they said like they had
the gauntlet halfway off of his hand
five more seconds they would have been
good star-lord could have thrown himself
with a nose all he wanted and it would
have been fine this I think gets into
the idea of the future timeline the
Doctor Strange foresaw like there was a
bit of a twist at the end before Doctor
Strange disappeared turning to ash he
says it was the only way so number three
what was dr. Strange's secret plan that
he says was the only way as he wound up
dying
Ironman begrudging Lee accepting what he
was talking about so there are a couple
things going on in this moment here
Ironman is forced to watch spider-man
melt away mr. star
I don't want to go like they have that
Doctor Who moment it's very effective
people all around me in the theater were
crying but earlier in the movie when
they're talking about the plan in Doctor
Strange says that there was only one way
they won one out of many millions of
possibilities way that they could win
the coming conflict he just makes a very
vague statement about what's to come so
you're left to wonder what the
conversation was after that happened you
make some assumptions because you're
like well they have this battle on Titan
maybe this is what he was talking about
but if that were the case then Doctor
Strange would have been more worried
when he gave the time stone to Thanos in
exchange for Iron Man's life so what I
think they're implying here is is that
there was a deeper plan at play they had
to let things play out this way so he
probably knew about how all this was
going to play out which is why he said
this was the only way an Iron Man
probably knew that even though he was
still extremely upset about how this was
going to go down we just keep in mind
that this was actually part of Doctor
Strange as planned
so we'll learn about that during
Avengers 4 like that will be the proof
in the pudding when Iron Man shows up
during Avengers 4 and says okay my buddy
the wizard here said that this was the
only way we could win is if Thanos did
this and then he'll reveal what the rest
of the plan is but we right now are left
at the cliffhanger so we're just
assuming that everything failed but I
think you know the big secret is is that
the plan didn't fail the plan is still
in motion but number two another big WTF
why did Scarlet Witch bench herself the
whole time that joke from a koieie was
perfect - why was she up there the whole
time because look at how powerful she is
they have those giant earth movers that
come underneath the show they're huge
they dwarf all these little people on
the ground Scarlet Witch picks them up
relatively easily and just throws them
away and she's also one of the only
people in the universe that we know that
has the power to destroy one of or more
than one of the Infinity stones if she
can do it - the mind gem she can
probably do it to the other gems - you
also see fanning through the Avengers on
his way to vision like he just throws
them aside like they're no big deal but
Scarlet Witch is a big surprise for him
he actually has to struggle again
with the power of five gems at his
command so if she can hold him at bay
when he has a nearly completed Infinity
Gauntlet she could have been useful much
earlier in the film but again like I
said during my review video a couple
days ago they were mostly paying off
emotional arts like this is all about
emotional terrorism and just making you
care about these characters and what
happened to them so that's why I think
they used her the way that they did and
now that she's turned to ash
she isn't immediately available to help
during Avengers 4 until they bring all
those people back but number one WTF why
didn't nuke fury call for Captain Marvel
to come help out sooner there was a
certain flow of information like they
say the Tony Stark is missing so there
are a lot of people on earth they don't
know what's happening on Titan because
they haven't got word to them yet now
mantis was able to call nebula but
that's because they were still on the
guardianship and they were within
communications range so there's a lot of
stuff happening on earth that people
only know about because of what banner
told them so the flow of information
hasn't been so great Nick Fury only
knows something is up as far as we know
because he just sees everything going
crazy in New York City but I think what
we'll find in the Captain Marvel movie
is the reason why she wasn't called
earlier during these other Avengers
conflicts is because she was probably
dealing with something even bigger out
in the Kree galaxy and remember this is
20 plus years after the events of the
Captain Marvel movie so if brie Larson
does not age between those two movies
there's something that happens to her to
keep her from aging either way I think
it has something to do with the turmoil
going on in the kree-skrull war so
there's like this giant intergalactic
war that's going on 20 plus years ago
she's probably dealing with that which
is why she doesn't come to help out
during age of Ultron or during the
original Avengers movie but just let me
know in the comments what were your
biggest WTF moments from the film like
either you know big gut-wrenching
moments or moments that you felt like
didn't make any sense either way there's
gonna be an ant-man and the wasp trailer
tomorrow there's a new round of that
Infinity Gauntlet giveaway all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber leave
a comment on the video uh name a winner
when I post that trailer video but I'll
also do a video for the missing
characters like Korg in Val
like people that we just did not see in
the movie but they left alive at the end
of thor ragnarok like where did some of
these people go did they escape what's
going on
so why you wait for everything click
here for my giant easter egg video it's
actually a pretty long video and click
here for my full review of the movie
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome we'll see you guys tonight
[Music]